following protests and calls for change
here in the valley the focus at home
turned to
how metro police operates orco mana
joins us live from metro police
headquarters tonight with a look at what
changes have been made
one year later orco well brian and
denise metro police
say some policies were adjusted even
before the murder of george floyd
and new legislation signed today by the
governor could bring
even more change tonight we spoke to
both metro and community activists
about where things stand
las vegas joining the nation in protest
following the murder of george floyd one
year ago
attention quickly turned to tactics used
by metro police
there have been numerous policy changes
and yes they are working while use of
force policies have been updated two new
bills in nevada signed into law tuesday
by governor steve sisolak
take things a step further one allows
the attorney general's office to do
pattern or practice investigations to
see if an issue with law enforcement
is just the isolated actions of one
officer or if it's part of a larger
systemic issue
the other severely limits no knock
warrants so the question is will this
make a difference
we're moving in the right direction
because it is not just a few bad apples
you know sort of that are ruining the
punch but activists add there's more
work to be done
it's a start but we still have we still
have to continue to move it forward
this is not nearly enough this is just
only the beginning
metro understands the road ahead is long
but the department is willing to work
with the community
i couldn't agree more with inviting the
ag's office
into our investigations we're an
organization that is not afraid
of progressive change the goal is to
create an inclusive environment and
honor george floyd's legacy
i hope that that we continue this track
together
those panelists you heard from joined us
for our breaking down
barrier special earlier this evening
they also touched on recruiting a more
diverse police force and dealing with
bad cops you can watch the full
conversation
on eight news now dot com reporting live
from metro headquarters tonight orca
mana 8 news now